each year microsoft research helps
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
okay it's a great pleasure to welcome
Emery burger who's visiting Microsoft
for a month and he'll be here so if
you're interested in talking to him this
plenty of opportunities emery is a
professor at university massachusetts
where he's been since 2002 Henry got his
PhD University of Texas in Austin his
researches investigated various aspects
of systems including operating systems
performance memory management and he's
published numerous interesting creative
articles some of which he's going to
talk about today he's also known for
delivering systems and having for
example the horde memory allocator which
is widely used for peril memory
allocation so it's a great pleasure
enjoy summer he's going to be talking
about multiprocessors and how to use
them all right thanks man right so the
title of my talk is exploiting
multi-core CPUs now so here's the issue
right so for years and years and years
you know ever since I was a baby the
people were saying you know one day dear
God there will be parallel computers on
everybody's desk you know and and you
know we all laughed and we thought the
professor was crazy then they kept
saying it over and over and over again
and then we started thinking oh maybe
it'll be true and i remember in like
nineteen ninety-two thinking it was just
around the corner um so I guess 14 years
is just around the corner so so it is
here finally we have these multicores
right so this is great except now we
don't really know what to do with them
so we thought we were going to do back
in the 80s and 90s was we would all be
using parallel programming languages and
that apparently has not panned out so it
seems that the current idea is let's
rewrite all of our software from scratch
but this has numerous disadvantages so
multithreading has lots of issues that
are well known you have to deal with
race conditions deadlock in addition you
know you can't just multi-thread your
code and say yay it works right in fact
just giving a threat to every task
doesn't scale at all so it's actually
quite a bit more complicate
unless you have to deal with scalability
bottlenecks and you really have to you
have to get into your coat and
understand it quite a bit so there's
been a lot of research recently on
addressing a one or two of these
problems which is this notion of
atomicity right so replacing locks with
atomicity or transactions and this is a
good idea it's a very popular direction
it doesn't really solve all the problems
it addresses some of them I put
functional programming up here in
question marks the functional
programming people are excited again
because they said look look you know the
kool-aid that we've been drinking and
we've been trying to give you you should
really have some now and so I you know
again it's still under the rubric of
rewrite everything right so I have to
take out all the code that's been
written you know there's a few hundred
lines or so out there that need to be
changed and then we write them right so
problem solved the other alternative of
course is parallelizing compilers and I
actually saw keynote and I will not
quote the person where the person said
you know now that we have multiple cores
we're going to get serious and we'll
really have parallelizing compilers and
I thought oh that's what it was we were
all frivolous before for 40 years we
were just fooling around so you know
maybe somebody will have some great
insight but but I think it's it remains
a very difficult problem right so this
talk is about two different approaches
that actually allow you to take
advantage of multi-course today without
rewriting any code so the idea here is
we're going to take legacy applications
and somehow do something with them that
lets us either make them run faster that
is take advantage of all of these cores
or increase reliability so the first
thing is a language for building servers
called flux and the second thing is a
system called die hard that is meant to
increase reliability so I'm going to
talk about both of these in turn and
first I'm going to talk about flux
ah so that's a good question so the
let's say uh we'll get there yeah
they're young um gap it's that you'll
see you'll see it's not much new code
alright so here's the motivating example
so I'm going to use this as a running
example through this talk the idea here
is is we're going to build a server so
we want to build the server and here's
this very straightforward idea of a
server I'm going to have a server in a
client the server is going to give up
images all right and it's going to store
them in raw format so it can make them
any arbitrary resolution but the client
only wants a particular resolution and
here we'll use this URL like approach
right you go and you want the Easter
Bunny 200 x 100 size 75 DPI right so the
image server can go ahead and dish up
this image first probably it's going to
look in a cache to see if it's given it
up recently right around Easter Sunday
this might be a good idea for this
particular image right but if it doesn't
find it it'll go and get it shrink it to
the appropriate size and there's your
Easter Bunny ok so this is a pretty
simple server the problem is if you go
ahead and you write this in the obvious
sequential fashion it doesn't scale at
all right so you could write a loop that
goes and waits for a client and sits in
the client it does all the processing
and gives it back this is not going to
scale up as you add clients in addition
you know if you have a thousand clients
right you're going to wait for 999
people in front of you so this is a
latency problem in addition if you have
multiple cores or even multiple
processors you know you're not going to
take advantage of it right so this is
well known so one thing we could do is
to use threads so we could for instance
be naive and have one thread per client
connection this has numerous problems I
guess I don't need to go into these one
of the serious problems is it mixes
programming logic with concurrency
control it's not so clear this is a big
problem if you do a thread for
connection the thread per connection
doesn't work you actually have to have
much more complicated software
architectures to get any reasonable
scalability and performance and by the
time you're done you know your server
this
very simple little elegant tiny piece of
server code that you had is embedded a
gigantic framework and you have no idea
what's going on yeah yes sir right so so
threats lemon tree is so um let's see
what the hell did I mean by that point
um so there's a number of different
issues so if you are going to use
multi-threaded software architectures
then you have to worry about the
synchronization primitives right and you
may have to change libraries you may
have to do all these things to work in a
particular framework so for instance you
can't just straightforwardly say we're
Windows land right there's apartments
and there's threads and there's
processes you know pick one well now
you're stuck with that one so that's
what i mean by so i think i meant by the
middle ear that's right uh yeah the
libraries so threads basically once you
say this is going to be threaded now
you're stuck with threads if you wanted
to say oh I meant to be event-driven
well it's not going to work yeah exactly
okay it's sort of baked in right okay so
uh this first half of the talk is about
this programming language called flux
it's a lightweight language basically
you can think of it in a sense as a high
concurrency glue and the glue is going
to combine components you're going to
direct them into a flow which
corresponds to the flow through the
server and then you'll add some
atomicity constraints so the components
are going to be unmodified C or C++ code
I have or Java kind of grayed out there
we do have a Java system but the focus
of this talk is on C and C++ the flows
are going to be these implicitly
parallel paths through these components
and I'll explain and show examples of
how this is going to work and then the
atomicity constraints are a very
high-level way of expressing mutual
exclusion so you give flux the flux code
you give it to the compiler and you give
it the components the compiler will
generate a number of things so the first
thing it can generate is it'll generate
a server right so the server will have
certain properties it's going to be
deadlock free notably its runtime
independence you can generate multiple
run multiple
should I say styles of servers just with
compiler switches and a different
runtime so for instance that you could
have threads the naive model you could
have thread pools you could have events
and more you can actually just keep
adding runtimes it also supports ball
and lares path profiling automatically
not going to go into this any further
that's the last mention of that but
something that's very nice for
performance prediction modeling it also
will generate a discrete-event simulator
for you that you can later use to
actually predict the performance of your
system as you add resources and clients
and measured under load and so on and
I'll show some results from that later
so first I'm going to talk about flux
I'm going to go through this exercise of
building up a server from pieces and
talk about these various aspects and
language I'll present some performance
results and talk about some future work
all right so we need to start the
program with main so the main influx is
a source node so a source node here is
basically intended to initiate the
connection so the source of all of the
stuff that's going to happen is going to
be connection from somebody you're going
to listen to something see if the laser
works and I can't see it at all it's
disadvantage of color blindness um or
yeah it works all right anyway so the
source here has this thing listen listen
say accepts a socket connection and then
it sends all of its data down to image
which is some know that's going to
produce an image for us okay the thing
to understand about source is that
source is conceptually executing inside
any of these sources in a separate
thread and running forever so a source
node is just constantly here waiting for
a connection processing it and going on
to the next connection all right okay so
now we want to build up an image server
so an image server here is going to
require a few pieces we need something
that's going to manage HTTP parsing we
need something to manage these
connections and sending stuff out over
sockets and then of course we need
something to compress these images into
JPEGs so we can actually go and get most
of this stuff just out on the web
there's sequential C code to do these
things in particular there's this live
jpg which is very convenient
which does exactly what we want so we're
going to do is we're actually going to
define it so image this whole thing
we're going to decompose into pieces and
we're going to implement these pieces by
making calls to these various libraries
so here this abstract node image is
going to be represented by a bunch of
other nodes in this flow and these notes
can themselves be abstract nodes which
you can think of is just yet another
flow or they can be concrete nodes which
actually mean they directly implement
some peace and call these things now i
should add here you do need to add a
type signature to these so that the flux
will know well whatever's coming out of
read request is actually legitimate to
co in to compress yes this is the point
of what you introduce the idea that
these nodes can be implemented with
concrete like a sequential code yes but
well does the system offer some way
which seems like the first question
asked to get concurrency and a finer
than component granularity because
things like that the big challenge to
get over it is that if each of these
components has written two sequential
code you have no way from the outside of
reasoning about how you might be able to
run it reentrant leader concurrently
correctly right okay so there are two
issues so the first issue is extracting
more concurrency and the second issue is
safety for legacy code right so I'm
really glad you asked these questions so
so the first one no no the first one is
actually really well motivated and
here's the deal you know if you have a
client-server architecture and you're
going to be serving a bunch of clients
right are you going to be serving let's
say a four-course are you going to serve
for clients you're probably going to
serve more clients than you have course
what that means is that the amount of
parallelism you have is actually
embarrassingly large if you consider it
eat from the point of view of each
client executing so I actually don't
care here about parallelism within each
of these chunks all I want is
parallelism across all of the clients so
once i have parallelism across all the
clients then i need to protect some
state so suppose this is not the case
for most libraries but pretend live jpg
is non reentrant and deals with some
global thing allow you to make sure that
only one threat at a time gets you
to live jpg if I'm actually using
threads okay it sounds like the answer
is no this system doesn't give you some
magical wave but if live jpg is not
written reentrant Lee no matter somehow
magically get it to run that's correct
sorry yeah all of a sudden there's a
bolt for the doors right because that's
true it seems like a lot of problems
become to chop up your code into us or
correctly independently executable
chunks which is an advanced over the
current state world but is sort of
roughly the same problem that you have
today when you sit down to try to make a
big lump of sequential code
parallelizable right you have to reason
about where there are great scenes in
yeah I'm not entirely convinced of that
but I think the more interesting thing
about it is to think of it as I want to
build functionality let's say I just
modular eyes my functionality into
sequential pieces right the code is
entirely sequential and somebody else is
going to handle all the parallel blue
and all that stuff for me so all I
really need to do is reason about my
program as sort of the way I've been
trained to do for the past and years and
sequential code which is hard enough
right okay okay and in addition this you
know software the only into my mind
really successful software component
model out there has been libraries and
libraries are already well encapsulated
and you know nice chunks of things that
people have delivered and used over time
so it's an attractive way to build
software I think right so I'm going to
get to the stuff about how you protect
the node execution but the key insight
here is that when it comes to
parallelism you know if I've a thousand
clients a thousand way parallelism is
plenty I don't need the parallelism
within each flow okay so control flow so
I mentioned caching before well caching
has a control flow right it says is this
a hit or is this not a hit so what I
want to be able to do is I want to be
able to distinguish between these cases
and have in effect two different flows
but what I don't want our variables I
don't want any programming language
stuff here at all I want it to be
very high level and easy for the
compiler to understand and in fact I
don't need variables what I do need is
what I call a predicate type so the idea
of a predicate type is here's this thing
test in cash test and cash is a black
box it just returns true or false it's a
boolean function the user supplies it
and I then can treat it as a type and I
can do this matching which will look
familiar to people who've used
functional programming or prologue the
idea is we're going to check this node
handler and if the third argument the
value is a hit that is if I apply this
boolean function to the third argument
and it returns true then it will do
nothing if on the other hand it doesn't
then it will fall through to this case
this means don't care don't care don't
care and then it will go to this other
flow so visually this is sort of what it
looks like it says check cash has a hit
handler does nothing otherwise handler
expands out to these other nodes that
actually go and fetch the thing from the
cash add it to the cash and then return
get a question yes that would be bad
otherwise yeah Tom it's just ringing
bells how is this related to what Jim
lara's stations there's stage sir yeah
thank you so so safe server is really a
runtime system it's not a language that
said you could view a stage server as a
potential candidate runtime system for
flux we haven't actually implemented
stage server like runtime system there's
nothing preventing us from doing so
because we basically know what all of
these are the arrows mysteriously
disappeared from here yep by the way
PowerPoint is anybody here from the
PowerPoint group yeah if you could if
you all know somebody or no one other
person tell them when you copy and paste
something from one presentation to
another like all the arrows mysteriously
disappear but then let's see if this
works I'm not going to do a lot if you
click on it and move it like a fraction
of an inch all the arrows suddenly rima
t realized
which is yeah so I forgot to do that
anyway yeah it's part of what language
the synchronization of these events are
tasks so yes yes and no I mean that's
just part of it so let me talk briefly
about stage server for those of you who
aren't familiar stage server is this
thing we're basically the idea is as
you're running a bunch of things in the
server so for instance we go and we have
read request read request if you were to
be able to take say a thousand of these
incoming connections and then execute
the same code on all of them and this
sort of advanced them to the next stage
all at once you get a lot of I cash
locality because you're executing the
same code over and over and over again
then you'd advance everybody forwards
and staged server works in this way it
sort of gets everybody to one stage
processes as many people as it can in
that stage then moves them to the next
stage so it's a kind of a hybrid event
driven and you know with queuing and
threads and you can have multiple
threads at the stages to dispatch and so
on it's somewhat similar to a system
called seta which is another staged
event driven architecture really I view
these as being implementation details in
effect right you can given this high
level structure the compiler can
generate any of the needed information
to hook it up to that kind of run time
system whereas when when Jim and Mike
were building their stage server web
server which admittedly was also quite a
piece of work because lots of
engineering went into it but they also
had to really adhere to this API is
there to write all this code themselves
and glue it all together and so we would
do that automatically okay all right so
here's the control flow so these are
these predicates types fine so now i
have caching well now we're back to this
problem of atomicity so about this cash
well I need to keep the cash consistent
so what does that mean it means I need
some sort of mutual exclusion so the way
I'm going to express this mutual
exclusion so I'm going to express it in
the language I cannot it's a design
decision I cannot put any flux into this
code the code is off the shelf I don't
get to go in and modify it and add locks
to things alright so what does that mean
I need to put it in flux so what we do
is we add these little sections we say
if you're in this node check cash or
complete or store in cash then you have
to own one of these locks so you can
think of them as locks and basically
it's a two-phase locking protocol so you
acquire all of them before entry and
then you release them so here these
alphas mean all of these three things
are exclusive now it may be the case a
complete also cannot run with some other
thing that has this Adam icity
constraint beta and that's how you do
this so if you want multiple things to
be prevented from running together you
just put the same symbol in these Adam
icity declarations and it's worth noting
that this doesn't just apply to a node
so here we have check cashing store and
cash and complete we could also make
this whole handler atomic just by saying
atomic handler and then giving it some
label yeah right so so complete actually
here so this is from with the exception
of the beta and the Greek letters this
is drawn from the actual example so we
have an image server example and
complete here the way it works is we
actually have some reference counts
because the images themselves are
maintained on the heat so you can't just
evict it and erase it from the cash
until you know nobody is using it so
when you walk out of a connection you
then complete and decrement the ref
count on the image you're holding it's a
good question ok so these Adam ously
constraints it was another question yeah
have bosses they can absolutely ok so so
this is fine but it's pretty coarse
grained so there are other things we
might want to do so we have some other
relaxed atomicity constraint in
particular we have reader-writer
constraints so by default an atom is d
constraint is a writer here we decorate
it with the exclamation
so it is a default if you want to you
can also add a question mark and then it
will generate reader-writer lakhs for
you in addition we have these per
session constraints and this takes a
little bit of explanation so suppose
this is motivated by a bittorrent
suppose you have some data and the data
needs to be updated on a per session
basis that is you've got some
downloading that's going on and you can
have multiple connections form from a
user to a bit torrent seed downloading
different pieces and so it
just needs to keep track of how much
you've downloaded because as this
fairness protocol to try to prevent
people from leaching bandwidth okay so
you know you're uploading stuff you're
downloading stuff it has to update this
state but you're independent of
everybody else in the world right that's
state whatever how many bytes you've
uploaded or downloaded has nothing to do
with however new bites are you know
downloads or uploads that Joe is doing
so what that means is that you really
want this granularity to operate on a
per session basis so you have this word
session and then you have to supply a
session function and the session
function takes output from the source
and hashes it to some integer and then
basically you can think of this as being
a hash table of locks so this gives you
fine grain locking ok all right so
suppose you did two phase locking and
you just acquired these things in the
order given well that would be bad
because you would quickly get deadlock
so here if you have a and you have B and
a go Z then y + B goes why then Z um
that's not good so what do we do so we
sort them so that's easy okay no
deadlock problem solved well not quite
so the problem is you know this
canonical lock ordering works fine and
you can you know sort all of the ones
within the constraints but when you have
abstract notes this does not work
because you can have this nesting so
here's a case where you could have
deadlock so here a is really just an
abstract note that holds b and c holds d
okay so what happens here
that a first you acquire the Z then you
require why but then c is going Y than Z
so now you have deadlock again so
basically the problem is is that you
can't just sort these things
independently you have to realize that
there is a hierarchy and you need to
somehow impose an order on them that
applies all the way down the hierarchy
right so the algorithm we employ here is
actually fairly straightforward this
little example all right what we do is
we elevate these constraints that is we
push them up in the hierarchy we sort
them and then we see if there's deadlock
and if there's still deadlock we push
things up again and we iterate until we
get to a fixed point so here we have but
we're before a just had Z as its Adam
icity constraint now the atomicity
constraint from B has been propagated up
and then sorted yeah what if B is
dependent oh right so B can be
controlled by a predicate right it
doesn't matter so basically you yeah so
if you if you say that B is atomic with
y that's what the you is the programmer
are saying right if you don't say that
then that's fine I mean the more serious
concern here is that this obviously
could lower the amount of concurrency
available in your program so the
compiler actually when it does this it
issues a warning and says I have to
elevate these constraints to avoid
deadlock maybe you want to do something
different okay this is the last piece of
language um and this is this is actually
something that took us a lot of
head-scratching to come up with so what
happens when you have an error so
suppose for example you go to load an
image right you request easter bunge all
right and it says oh there's no Easter
bunge right I need to do something else
well seta which is this alternate model
had this mechanism where you say oh
there was an error like here now I need
to send back a message to my
now the predecessor needs to be able to
deal with this error and then this needs
to be able to deal with this error and
so on so it's like manual exception
handling and what this means is that
every single component you write has to
be prepared for any arbitrary error that
could happen downstream which seems to
break modularity to me not only that now
you need to rewrite the code or you need
to write these crazy wrappers that
somehow can deal with us so what we do
instead we basically just have an
alternate path so we say if an error
happens in read for reading from disk we
go out of the normal flow and here we go
to this 404 which just prints up the
form the horrible 404 message so I
didn't say this was great error handling
in this particular case but you could
imagine a message that says write the
file you attempted to find is not
available right and that would be fine
so the nice thing about this is that you
know it doesn't muddy the normal flow of
the program and it allows you to have
these custom error handlers wherever you
want you just have to have this one
piece and it goes right from the error
that you wanted now one extension that
we've looked into we haven't actually
implemented it yet because we have these
paths that are coming with you know
these numbers that uniquely identify
every path through the code we could
actually have arbitrarily baroque error
handling we could have a path right if
you went here then here then you know
somewhere else somewhere else then here
then we could have an error handler for
that and then we would have to modify
the language to allow something more
complex on the left hand side we haven't
yet see the need for it but it seems
like a cute thing and well turkey
thieves like once you add these kind of
errors I rose the heart keeps gone I
have to look at my thing as a flat list
of atomic two nodes because otherwise
your boxes state they have no funny on
the output edges right they okay it's no
longer a sort of a nice box yeah so we
constrain the errors basically to be
sinks so when you have one of these
error paths it basically is going to be
the end it's a termination so you could
imagine having it be less constrained
but i think that wave makes it it makes
it fairly simple to reason about
but I agree I mean ultimately you know
if you have any sort of error handling
if you don't do it in this sort of
scoped away with exceptions then you
know you're breaking modularity away but
unfortunately it's not clear what the
alternative is okay so this is the
almost complete code for the image
server I say almost complete because
I've admitted the type signatures of the
concrete nouns right which is not
terribly interesting so I argue that
this is fairly short it's not much new
code and it allows you to write this
image server that actually scales and
performs well and does all these things
yes okay yeah does it eat this um okay I
let's see so there is not anything more
powerful as a return value from a
predicate type than a boolean but its
input argument could be anything so if
you wanted to say you know at least
seven for your predicate type that would
be fine just think of that you know
think of this thing here this hit which
I left off the typedef for think of that
little function as being whatever you
want that just comes from whatever this
input argument is right so this argument
that comes into handler could be
anything okay all right so good so
that's that's basically the overview of
the language now I'm going to briefly
present some performance results so this
wouldn't be terribly interesting if it
performed like crap right so yeah I'm
not a probably be better to talk about
that offline briefly it's the compilers
all written in Java and it generates see
output and yep and then it's so right so
it depends on the particular runtime
there's a back end for every different
runtime and then the back end transforms
things differently so all right I'll
talk about
briefly so if you want to do so you can
do a naive thread model the naive threat
model goes from a source and produces
one thread that executes all the way
through to completion the thread pool
model is similar except obviously build
thread pools and there's an event-driven
system that basically turns this thing
into an FSM and you know giant switch
statement and says all right I just
finished stage one now I go to to write
if I'm here then I have to do this check
to decide whether i go to stage seven or
stage 12 and so on in an event-driven
system so an event-driven system on what
you do is you basically uh don't you
have threads that handle blocking system
calls but most of the computation is
actually done by one main thread okay
right so um right but you get good
latency for others not yet now we
actually have another interesting of
backends well I'm not so sure about that
the the thing that we wanted to compete
against and I'll show you in a second
were these two systems capriccio and
seta capriccio is this fast user level
threading system it's a follow-on to
seta that actually uses it looks like
threads and it uses some compiler
supports make this efficient and then
set as the system I described earlier so
we've built for servers so far i have
over here on the right the lines of flux
code obviously it's not the lines of c
code right in these servers this is just
the new lines and flux and so one of the
nice things is you know why jpeg just
downloaded live jpg and plugged it in
PHP you know god forbid you have to
write that from scratch and so that's
just shipped as a library like many of
these things are so i'm going to show
you just one benchmark here which is a
variant of spec web 99 and then go over
these various run times and the
comparison yeah which write some new c
code it depended i mean you have to
write some sort of glue for some of
these things right and so the amount of
that varies i believe that it's in the
paper exactly how many lines
I don't know what it is off hand okay so
here's the quick run time graph so we
took a web server we generated three
different flux versions which are all
blue we have this one down here which is
the naive one thread per connection that
unsurprisingly does not scale too well
and then we have this event driven and
thread pool system which are way up over
there the thing at the very top just
above us is capriccio which actually
outperformed us here I have a student
who made a new runtime system which is
actually very cool and we now are
outperforming capriccio but I mean that
wasn't really the goal the goal was to
match it right the goal is to be able to
take stuff off the shelf and come
credibly within very high performance
system and then set up set as a sad
story and let me just leave it at that
that's how setup performs okay so so
we're doing 2x better than a paper that
made it into sauce p 001 so that's not
too bad yeah going back to the runtime
questions yeah just focus question if
you're doing it event-driven style it
seems like the problem is that naively
you would have sort of one event pump
per processor right and you respect the
exclusions just right there's always the
problem I wondered how you solved it
where if every processor could be in a
particular component simultaneously
because it has no concurrency constraint
but that component inconveniently makes
a bunch of blocking calls right such
yeah you know perform other work right
how do you how do you work around that
so you need to know in advance that's
going to put your thread to sleep which
is inconvenient right that you want to
shut it off to a worker thread yeah dude
you inspect the component or is this
declaration now at all black boxes
basically we have a shim and extensive
set of shims it shim all blocking calls
and route them to to help her dress
that's right exactly okay so this is the
discrete event simulator story so we ran
uh this is actually the image server I
should have written that up here so we
ran the image server on a 16 way son but
what we did is we disabled 15 of the
processors and we wanted to see you know
to go ahead and collect the data and
then run the simulator just
how would behave as we added processors
so we actually model in the discrete
event simulator you know the the locks
you know each lock has a Q you know you
model all of these things the incoming
threads etc this is all generated
automatically the only thing that's
missing are some observed parameters
like you know arrival rate and so on so
we did as we ran it on one cpu and then
we ran the simulator so it's no real
surprise it comes pretty close right so
then we went and we did it for all of
the different numbers of CPUs for their
powers of 2 so 2 4 8 16 so we ran the
code and the parameters we used we're
only the parameters from the one
processor run so everything else is
extrapolated from that run and using the
flux runtime and select simulator and
you can see that the observed
performance and the predicted
performance are remarkably close so the
simulator faithfully captures the
structure and concurrency control of the
flux program and this happens for free
which is nice yeah
yes do you have an evaluation along
resource consumption lines as opposed to
um so one of the things about capriccio
that you're talking about basically what
they did is they use some compiler
analysis to try to control the size of
the thread stacks right so the default
thread stack is you know in Norma's and
you run out of thread stacks real fast
right so the problem with capriccio and
this is a roundabout way of getting to
your answer to answer your question is
it there is no multiprocessors story at
all it only works on a single processor
and i hassled them about this you know
and then it's coming soon this was a
year and a half ago I I mean their user
level thread scheduler only works on
yoona processor and they've never been
able to actually adequately address the
problem with multiple processors so
while i agree with you know the idea
that shrinking these threats tax is fine
if you're going to go to a pure thread
model you know using thread pools or
using some other runtime system you get
out of that situation and the capriccio
story is i think half-baked at this
point
to tackle the problem of sort of server
capacity by reducing resource
consumption for the threading model yeah
my question was well how do you compare
to that right it sounds like the answer
as well capriccio isn't really all the
way there yet there's it's hard to make
a yummy we could make a quantitative
comparison but very it's really unfair
right I mean the fact that matters is
that you could make a much cheaper
system that just is single threaded uh
that you know has no resource
consumption but that kind of sucks so I
figure capriccio is still sort of apples
and oranges yeah but uh but you know the
problem remains if you're going to use
real threats threats tax are big okay so
let me talk very briefly about some
future work so so who are these people
so the guy on the left is a grad student
named Jake absorber guy in the middle is
one of my colleagues Mark corner also
professor at UMass and the guy on the
right is a zoologist and the thing
that's really important is what's in
marks hands which is this little turtle
called a wood turtle and so this picture
here shows a wood turtle that stuff on
the shell is not natural those are
passive radio transmitters so here's the
thing the wood turtle is an endangered
species in western Massachusetts how do
they know that it's endangered species
the way they know is because the number
one and number two predators of the wood
turtle our cars and lawnmowers and the
number of dead turtle bodies has been
dropping okay but how many turtles are
there where do they live what do they do
nobody really knows it's okay so what
they do is you get you know the grad
students of the zoologist out there with
these big like walkie talkie things with
antennas and they walk around in the
swamp looking for turtles all right and
then they ping one and they find it and
there you know real excited they run
over and they find the turtle then they
take the gps out of their pocket and
they write down the reading then so if
you're lucky you get one reading per day
over a week per sub small sample of
turtles which is a little bit
unsatisfactory so we're actually in the
midst of deploying these little systems
on the backs of the turtles so they have
to be very very very small Massachusetts
is very strict about these things
they've restricted us to four ounces now
I contend that this turtle is tough and
it could Vic and swim okay with a pound
but uh but Massachusetts doesn't agree
with me so so we're stuck with four
ounces so four ounces is really light
and the problem is we want to be able to
get high fidelity information high
frequency we want gps we wanted all the
time but you know if you've got a thing
that's this big you know what would be
ideal is a car battery right to run the
GPS for more than two days but the car
battery will clearly sink the turtle so
we can only really put in a tiny little
lithium battery and what that means is
we need some way of harvesting energy
from the environment the good thing is
these guys are cold-blooded so they've
warm themselves by setting themselves
which is perfect so we have a little
solar cell on top so in this tiny little
case we have the solar cell a GPS a
radio transmitter so if you get near
another turtle you can broadcast
information about where you've been and
share and then if one of those turtles
happens to get near one of these masters
stations that we've set up on lampposts
then they can upload their information
to the 20 gig hard drive that's there
okay the problem is from a programming
standpoint this is complex because you
can't just say oh run GPS all the time
if you're on GPS all the time the
battery is drained in an hour and we'd
like the thing to run forever at least
for the lifespan of the turtle let's say
okay which is maybe not forever with all
the lawn mowers but anyway so so we have
this problem that the power is going up
and down so we've extended flux and we
have it's a terrible name I admit but we
call it a flux okay ah and the inside
here is that client server is actually
remarkably like sensors what a sensors
do there's events coming in from the
environment and they respond to them and
the events are asynchronous and can
happen at the same time and guess what
that's more or less what servers do
right so
we want we found that it's a good match
at least conceptually but we needed to
address this problem power states so
what we've done we actually have a way
for the programmer to specify a bunch of
power states in a lattice and then you
can decorate these flows with these
power states and so if you're in flow
and it says power state hi it won't run
if you're in power state low so it's
sort of another argument that controls
dispatch and then we've built a very
sophisticated runtime model that
actually incorporates days of sunlight
data in western Massachusetts for
different times of the year it is
actually pretty sunny turns out but
tries to predict how much Sun is coming
if I'm in this low power state and i
haven't uploaded in a while maybe i do
want to go and do the gps thing or turn
on the radio transmitter and so on
because I odds are good that sun is
coming right so there's all sorts of
these things we can do and we
dynamically adapt and so on so the cool
thing is is that we can push all of that
information into the runtime and then
the programmer who actually is doing the
program logic just doesn't have to think
about it at all this is so far turned
out to be a real win the programmers
before who are working on this these
grad students were using this thing
called Nessie and they're completely
stymied it was just too difficult to
reason about all right good so there's
the conclusion of flux right so you can
use sequential C code you can build
these servers maybe you can build
turtles and you get predictable
performance etc right so that's it for
performance so if you're not interested
in anything but performance you know you
can leave now the next part of the talk
is not about performance yes man well
this is nice I think you kind of set us
up at the beginning right you said well
one of the problems is we have cores and
we don't know what to do with it all
right which means that problem is
finding parallelism and then you showed
us this embarrassingly parallel problem
right or that's not the problem the
problem is kind of controlling parallels
yeah and not having
right do you have a story for the other
problem to the magic story we're like
we're extract parallelism from spec
application servers are embarrassingly
Harold and this is like the most
stunning infrastructure and architecture
that as well and people building servers
they know exactly to build it this way
right so yes and now so I would argue
that it's still a mater remains a matter
of controversy as to what the best
runtime system is and how to build these
servers and it remains complex and
difficult to build these servers okay uh
you know people spend a lot of time they
don't know how the server is going to
behave I myself have personally
consulted for people trying to address
their server performance babe Kirk
Resnick's right right so um that said
you know I okay I'm gonna say something
controversial film um I don't stain I'm
sorry I have never done this before um I
don't I have not yet been told what the
great application class is for which we
need multicores because that's not how
it worked we don't have multicores
because of the crying application need
for multi course we have multicores
because the architecture community ran
out of ideas okay so i don't know of any
application for which we really need to
extract all this parallelism does word
need all this parallelism maybe god
forbid right um but that said I think
that there's one application class that
we know very well does need parallelism
and its servers and it still has been
difficult to program these servers and
reason about them and produce correct
servers in fact I know I'm going to
finish here because I'm going to run out
of time for the rest of the talk but I
know of a major commercial server
serving millions of people that recently
deadlocked right that sucks and it is
just testament that people really are
still not solve this problem which of
course motivation for the whole
atomicity and transactional memory line
of research
in a sense that unified by specifying my
walks incorrectly yeah yeah yeah so
actually yeah it's nice but I think it's
only a really small step so well we can
quibble about the size of the step but I
actually am working with with my kicks
on using static analysis to look inside
these pieces of C code to verify the
correctness of these things okay so well
I have eight minutes is that right um
this will be a blast I have till 12 oh
okay all right okay that's fine all
right so if you've already seen this I
know a couple of you have all right so
um this is joint work with Ben this
stems from work I did when I was here
last summer so what does this address
this addresses the problem of memory
safety so you know you've got these c
and c++ programs and they have problems
right some of you may have heard that
their memory unsafe this is a small list
of some of these memory problems so you
can have a double free you can have an
invalid free we free the wrong thing you
can do an uninitialized read buffer
overflows and dangling pointers so this
talk is actually just about the heap
it's about memory errors that occur in
the heat not going to be talking about
the stack at all all right so how do we
deal with this so there's several ways
of dealing with this problem the first
is the most popular way which is to do
nothing at all right so this is the
approach taken by windows and the seed
library from canoe and so on your
program may run may do something crazy
it may crash it's unclear there is this
piece of work called rx which is out of
why why Joe's group in Illinois and this
one the idea is I run the program if it
crashes then I roll back to a previous
state and I do something like pad out
memory allocations and so on and hope
that it continues to go on what this
doesn't do it's fine but what it doesn't
do is
first it only detects crashes you know
you could be off doing god knows what
and that's not going to show up as an
error and second it's not really
guaranteed to fix the problem but it has
been shown to work for some some cases
so another system which is also unsound
but will absolutely definitely continue
is called Phil you're oblivious
computing this is from Martin wine arts
group so how many of you have have not
heard of this after okay well at least
at least three good alright so here's
the idea I have a compiler which detects
all out of bounds and other invalid
operations when you detect such an
operation like an invalid read I read
from nowhere then in the first
incarnation of this work you make up a
value ok in fact Martin proposes a whole
sequence of values and then the values
should loop because that will ensure
termination and things like this and
then if it does something bad again then
you again fabricate a new value and if
you right into an illegal area either
you drop it or you cash it so that maybe
you read it again next time ok they will
definitely continue what it's doing is
unclear but it will definitely continue
to run ok so another alternative which i
think is more popular at least it
increases the comfort level is a fail
safe approach as soon as something bad
happens you fall on your sword you say
oh god I'm about to overflow something
and then that's it game over right so
this suffers from a few disadvantages so
the first is you know you really first
this is a see only solution and it
requires your C source all of your
source and it instruments it the
slowdowns can be substantial so you can
get from thirty percent to 20 X
slowdowns which is a lot so it also
stops as soon as you have any error at
all and some errors could be benign let
me give you an example of benign error i
allocate 16 bytes for every 12 bite
object then I write the 13th bite which
is benign right because that
is not going to be used by any other
object but any of these compilers will
immediately complain and halt right if
they knew the memory allocation layout
they could certainly check for it and
that would be okay but other errors
could also be benign that's not really
the main issue the main issue is that
20x slow down makes it useless for
deployment yes Mormons I'm not aware of
it remember the names of handsome okay
that'd be interested to hear okay um so
what what I'm going to talk about now is
this tool called die hard so diehard is
going to provide something that we call
probabilistic memory safety so what this
will give you is not one hundred percent
sound but also not zero percent sound
it'll be somewhere in between the idea
is you're going to run correctly in the
face of errors with high probability and
I'll actually be able to say what that
probability is it relies on two things
first it relies on a fully randomized
memory manager and I'll explain how that
works and this is going to increase the
odds of benign memory errors and it's
also going to ensure that every user is
going to see a different key play out
which will turn out to be important in
particular the other thing you can do is
you can go ahead and replicate the
process you can take from a process X
and have three copies of it alright and
we're going to run these replicas
simultaneously and vote on the results
and this has numerous benefits which
I'll explain both analytically and
empirically but at a high level it can
detect all kinds of errors can detect
errors that cause crashes and it can
detect errors that just go off and do
crazy things right because they won't
agree so what this does is it gives you
a trade-off you give me more space and
more cores and I'll give you more
reliability so let me explain briefly
how we're going to describe some
semantics to these programs that are
broken so we can reason about them so
normally in the pl community if you have
a memory error you consider the pro
have to have no meaning it has this this
symbol which means bottom right it has
absolutely no meaning at all but if we
consider the case where we have an
alligator that presents the view of an
infinite keep a heap that is literally
infinitely large to the program then you
can make some erroneous programs
completely sound so think about it if
you have an infinite heat all news can
be fresh that is as soon as you need
more memory you just go get more because
you have an infinite amount of memory
right and you don't care about delete
because why the lead is just to reuse
memory and I've got so much I don't need
to delete any right so this immediately
gets rid of a large class of errors in
addition you know the heap is infinitely
large why not make every object
infinitely large to write you know why
not so if every object is infinitely
large and it's impossible to have a
buffer overflow you can't overwrite some
other wives and so on right so the cool
thing about this is that for correct
programs basically this is transparent a
correct program cannot portably detect
whether it's running on an infinite heap
or not right it could go ahead and count
you know all right I've allocated a
hundred objects and you know but that's
that's no proof of anything you could
just be in a larger memory space right
the cool thing though is that you have
programs that used to have no meaning at
all and now they're sound so what we're
going to do is we're going to actually
approximate these innocent heaps but
what we call em heaps and this is going
to provide probabilistic soundness so M
here is the factor of increase over the
maximum amount of memory required so if
your program needed 100 bytes and M is
to then it'll consume 200 bytes so here
are a couple ways you could imagine
doing this you could pad all the memory
allocations right I asked for 8 i'll
give it 16 and I could defer the
allocations right which is like I'm
going to wait until two times as many
objects have been freed so this would be
reasonable it's simple but it doesn't
provide any protection at all for larger
overflows so if you have an overflow of
size 9 and your pad was of size 8 then
you have zero sound them right in
addition it's deterministic if you just
say I'm
adding every object by this much and I'm
deferring by this much if I have a bug
that crashes one of those things it's
going to crash everybody right so that's
not desirable so we propose to randomize
the heat that is we're going to take the
heat and we're going to randomly lay out
all the objects within the heat this is
going to provide probabilistic
protection against errors and it's going
to be independent across seams which
means that this replica thing will
actually work and it also means that
multiple users will potentially be able
to avoid these bugs can hit one and
won't hit everybody else now there is a
big question mark here though how on
earth can we randomize the heat
efficiently you have a question anything
to do with another class of memory early
you didn't mention which that a program
might fabricate a heat pointer
addressable or is there some interaction
you mean we forge a pointer and then we
go and write to it say when classifier
is you you're doing pointer arithmetic
you never know so you effectively have a
fabricator yeah that's right so the
analysis is actually done assuming that
that's the model that you use for buffer
overflows did you fabricate a pointer
somewhere into the heap and right so yes
the info okay that's the question right
so yeah no I mean overshoot an allocated
object yep thats Ruth distinct from just
making up and that's right which isn't
relatable that's right so we're going to
get to this in the analysis section but
in fact that's exactly what we do is we
just assume you have a random point or
somewhere in the heap that does
something and then what is the
probability of avoiding that kind of
error ok all right so um so we first
went to try to randomize the heat said
ok let's start with the normal heat it's
a free list base team um well how do you
randomize a list well ok it's clear to
see how you could randomized a list but
then how do you do it efficiently that's
not clear more importantly these free
list based heaps are really susceptible
to small errors right so the free list
based heaps typically have an object and
they have a little header that's before
the object well if you have a one-bite
right into that header game over
right it's corrupted how do you deal
with a double free right well you can
check some magic cookie potentially to
see if the object is freed that could be
corrupted you could scan through the
whole list to try to find the object
that would not be smart right so double
fries are a bit of a problem so we then
said well what else could we do and
Wilson in 1990 had proposed this idea of
using bitmaps for memory allocators but
when which is fine but if you're
randomly allocating objects in a space
using bitmaps you can end up with
catastrophic fragmentations let me show
you what I mean these big boxes are
pages and now I'm going to randomly
allocate these objects right now I want
to allocate a page well I'm hosed right
there's no place for me to slide that
page into and moreover it's not really
that efficient to go search through a
gigantic bitmap to find an empty space
there Wilson proposed a few things but
they're all tricks like you know read 32
bits at a time but okay that's you know
it's fine but if you have you know
millions of bits it's not really helping
that much okay you could build that's
right so yeah that's right so you could
build a hierarchy of bitmaps you then
have actually have an issue of overlap
across the bitmaps so if you say so I'm
not going to go into this slide if you
have this space in this space well you
really want to be able to put an object
in the middle as well right so it's not
that simple it's doable I think it's
doable yeah yeah it's definitely doable
it's not that's not really the issue
here though the issue really is
randomization right so if I want to
randomly allocate objects in this bitmap
heap I'm going to end up with
fragmentation so what we do to solve
this is we segregate all these sizes of
objects into their own distinct region
of the heat so i should add the
implemented version of die hard that you
can actually get now there's a more
sophisticated heap structure but this is
simple to understand so conceptually all
we do is we carve the heap up into
chunks and then each chunk is devoted to
a different size of object and here are
their powers of two so for instance
these green things indicate allocated
objects the ones in the bitmap mean that
they're allocated a zero means that
they're free
so here this is an object of size say
eight these are objects of size 16 and
so on so the key thing to realize here
is first a bit doesn't represent a word
or a smaller chunk anymore it represents
an entire object right so sir we don't
have to find the right space to fit if
we go to the right partition we can
immediately find the fit moreover you
can't get any sort of fragmentation if
there's space available that force a
size 8 object in the size 8 heap there's
space available right it can't be broken
up so this is crucial so now how are we
going to do allocation and free so
allocation turns out to be pretty quick
we're going to compute the size class of
the requested object which we can do
with a quick vlog operation and then
we're going to randomly probe the bitmap
for a free and it turns out that this
actually is very much like a form of
hashing and the expected number of
probes if M is to that is you always
have over-provisioning x factor of 2 the
expected number of probes is bounded by
above by 2 so it's fast alright so we go
we say I have an object of size 8 i'm
going to allocate from here I randomly
flip an object good that one was was not
free I claim it okay and so that's going
to be quite so what about free free is
very straightforward it's basically a
arithmetic you find out which pointer
you know which part of the heap you're
in and then we can add some validity
checking was did you really mean to free
this object right did you try to free
this pointer instead of this so we can
check to see if you've aligned it to the
right address that's just quick pointer
math if you double free it has no effect
setting a bit to one a thousand times
still one and then you know 20 I mean in
this case you just reset the bits so
this has this benefit of avoiding these
two errors so here's an object we're
going to free and we flip the bit very
simple alright great so now here is a
heap after sub number of objects have
been allocated so the numbers here just
denote the ents object allocated in that
partition so the first one second one
third one fourth one fifth one etc so
every time I run
program I'll have a different heat so
the errors across the heaps will now be
independent so what this means is you'll
get this is say somebody else's heap and
same program running and the heap layout
is totally different so pretend we're
running I guess I should change this to
ie for this audience but pretend we're
running Mozilla Mozilla has an overflow
which happens and it overflows from
object to let's say well that's going to
stomp on object for in the heap on top
but in your mozilla it might be that it
just lands in some empty space and the
odds of it landing at empty space
intuitively are basically you know 5050
right if i randomly choose and the heap
is completely full and i just pick some
random place to land i'm going to land
on an empty space with a fifty percent
chance okay if the heap is twice exactly
alright and I'll go through all of this
stuff so so this is great um you know
fewer people's mozillas will crash let's
say well great for Mozilla um again
should have changed it to IE um but
maybe I don't care about other people
maybe I'm a selfish bastard and I want
my mozilla not to crash right you know
the other people's can crash but mine
better not crash so here's what we can
do so we actually do is we have this
approach where we replicate the process
the whole process and then all input
gets broadcast two different replicas so
here we have three replicas each replica
has a different random seed which means
it's heap is going to be differently
randomized then when we go to output all
of these guys send their results
whatever the output is let's say this is
a standard in standard out program so it
reads a chunk of memory gets replicated
to everybody they go when they execute
then they go to write something to
standard out they fill the standardout
buffers and then the buffers are
compared and you vote that is you try to
see if anybody doesn't agree and a
replica doesn't agree you say that
replica had an error now the assumption
is if replicas do agree because the
errors are independent and the odds of
having an identical he play out our
banishing Lee small you assume that
consensus equals correct yes um so
there's a barrier synchronization on the
output and yes that's right yeah but in
this case is he price no got ya no no
this is like standard out yeah yeah if
we were to i mean you could imagine
capturing things that a fine grain like
that certainly you get an enormous slow
down that they don't use that the disc i
do assume they use the disc but so
here's the deal the initial prototype of
this that was describing the paper only
intercepted standard in standard out and
a few other things notably time of day
because web servers for instance right
logs and if you're going to be
intercepting file i/o and everybody has
a different time you're gonna have a
problem so what we want to be able to do
is to have the enth call of time return
the same result across all the replicas
the same is going to be true for file
i/o and four sockets and all of those
things you know if you get a socket read
then and it comes off of you know
whatever this particular socket ideas
has to be the same for everybody when
you write you have to buffer everybody's
rights and then you send it out to the
socket just one of them the one that
passes yeah so it basically if so you
can have non determinism in your
application as long as it doesn't bleed
to output right so that's actually an
excellent point about crypto um but yeah
so that's the deal right now this
particular infrastructure only handles
nondeterministic output stream but i
think crypto i mean if the random number
is not generated on a per if it's not
generated a fresh by every replica if
it's you know something that's stored
but it's scripted graphic then I think
it's okay okay so let's go through some
results so I'm going to show you some
analytical results I'm going to give you
a flavor with pictures of how this works
and then show you the math imax
going to show you the case where the
protection the diode offers is the
lowest which is for buffer overflows the
reason for this is we modeled buffer
overflows very aggressively as these
random writes that I described earlier
I'm not going to talk about
uninitialized reads or dangling pointer
errors for which the protection is the
best but you can look in the paper for
that and then talk about some empirical
results notably runtime overhead and
then how it actually works in the face
of errors so here's the analytical
results so suppose we have a buffer
overflow the overflow here is I randomly
choose some object to smash that's my
model not really a typical overflow but
it's the most conservative one for the
analysis so if the heap is half-full
right you have a 50-50 chance of
avoiding the overflow right and 50-50
chance of having the overflow land on
something allocated so here we're happy
because the random right just stomped on
some free data and so we don't care but
here we're sad couldn't find a smiley
face sad face we're sad because it
landed on live data and we consider that
to be a failure even if the live data
has never read all right so what about
another overflow right so we have only a
quarter chance of surviving two
overflows and only an eighth chance of
surviving more overflows so the
probability of avoiding and overflow
that is in the face of these overflow
repetitions the probability of having no
impact of this overflow is at least one
half to the M which is not that great
right it's better than zero but it's not
that great okay but the replicas helped
a lot so here let's say that all we care
about is avoiding a crash to get
correctness you actually need at least
two replicas but if you want just the
program to keep running let's say we
just have one replica this is simpler
for this description so what we're going
to do is we're going to say well we have
a 50-50 chance of landing in you know in
bad in bad and in bad the probability of
an overflow in every single replica is
actually low it's an eighth so the
chance of avoiding an overflow in one
replica it
one is 78 which is pretty good so the
replicas really buy you a lot so this is
the formula up top where F is the amount
of free space and h is the amount of
heap size so if you have said you know
the maximum fullness is a half you
obviously could go up and you could go
down so your heap could be less full or
could be more full no more than a half
full and is the number of overflows and
k is a number of replicas and so this
graph depicts the probability of
avoiding an overflow of one object the
purple bar is when the heap is an eighth
full the mm maybe I should have said
purple for this one the reddish bar is a
quarter and then the green bar or yellow
bar is a half full as you can see that
the probability is pretty high with with
one replica for I'm sorry when it's an
eighth full only fifty percent as
described earlier but as you add
replicas three four five six the odds
get higher and higher that you're going
to avoid these errors yeah
I just mentioned for this analysis we're
going to assume crash failure that's
right yeah it's a weak version of
success right success means keeps
running if you really want to be
stronger you have to say at least two
but at least two actually works okay to
you get the same sort of geometrically
increasing odds of avoiding overflow as
you add replicas but it's simpler to
think of at least one than at least it
okay so so what about runtime so you
know this randomized allocator you would
think would be expensive because it's
you know randomly allocating for
Christ's sake right so I ran it this is
just you know no replication just the
randomized teeth against some well-known
hilariously allocation intensive
programs these are widely used in the
memory management community as kind of
stress tests I mean some of these things
spend like Robo op i believe spends
forty percent of its time allocating and
freeing objects all right that's all it
does I think that it allocates and
freeze over its lifetime 1.5 billion
objects but its peak footprint is like
20k okay to give you a sense so we ran
this against windows and you can see you
know Malik is the black bar so it's
normalized to Malik and you know in some
cases it actually does better uh and and
surprisingly significantly better and on
average it's pretty close yeah it's the
usage time because you're spreading your
load on a much wider variety of pages so
you lose locality this is not allocation
time that's right this is that it's a
good question I should have stressed on
this y-axis this is normalized total
execution time this is not allocation
time but ok for example done that would
explain why robot would actually perform
a lot better because its footprint is so
small that on none of this locality
really matters um that that's unclear
that's unclear I mean if you think about
a free list allocator freelist allocator
that uses say stack like discipline
right i allocate a bunch of objects and
I free them all i allocate them I free
them I'm reusing the same memory over
and over again that is definite
not happening in a randomized alligator
right you have no chance at all that
you're reusing the same object iteration
after iteration in fact in this
particular case they're spread over if I
believe if i recall correctly 32
megabytes of space and you'll see that
this is partly a function of the windows
allocator as I'll show on the next slide
so this is run time on Linux these are
the same applications and you can see
the Black Bart here is the new life c
alligator and then the blue is the
budweiser collector this is just to show
that we're sort of close to conservative
garbage collectors in overhead but the
green bar here is die hard so this is a
lot different right before it was almost
the same and here it's like 1.4 so I
speculate that the reason for this is
locality I know that the reason for the
giant bar on the right is locality it's
TLB okay now these are all results for
the initial version of die hard which
had one giant heap ok the new version of
die hard that's the one point overton is
adaptive and it grows to fit so you
would never get into the situation like
you have with t wolf over here on the
other hand even including these outliers
the geometric mean this is a like ten
percent ten percent with randomized
allocation right so you know locality
shmoke ality right you know this is
application performance so it's kind of
unclear that locality at least at the l1
and l2 level make that much of a
difference and remember this is a I mean
I tuned the hell out of the allocator
but it's still making random numbers
right every allocation is still several
multiplies and mathematical operations
and so on so all right I will say I've
run this under valgrind which measures
you know you can run it and get cash
values out and yeah the locality is a
disaster but its actual impact on
runtime is surprisingly small caches are
big enough I guess is
a take-home message force for many
applications clearly it's not true for
every application yeah yeah okay right
so um what it let me put it this way it
means two things so first if your object
size is close to your l1 sighs then
jamming objects together doesn't matter
right I mean ideally the best situation
for caching is you allocate you get
object level caching I use this object
and there's the object right you'd like
prefetching and other things to happen
but this totally undermines prefetching
right you you know you could have been
allocating in a linear fashion with the
linux alligator and you're definitely
not doing that now no prefecture is
going to figure this out so you tell me
I mean clearly force it say you know
your mileage may vary but I would
certainly say that spec doesn't make
much of difference okay so fine one time
that was I promised I wasn't gonna say
anything about performance but I guess I
did I would say that it's a credible
story you end up with the geometric mean
of about ten percent penalty right you
automatically get double free protection
and invalid free protection by the
nature of the allocator so what about
other kinds of errors so in addition to
you know these days other kinds of
errors that we naturally go for free we
want to be able to show that we can
protect against dangling pointers and
overflows that's the whole point so what
we did is we will a little error
injector they can take a running program
and eject certain faults so overflows
are easy you know you ask for 8 i'll
give you four right bing overflow
dangling pointers are more complicated
you have to run the program once you get
the list of all the allocated objects
and then you free objects a little bit
too soon so for the dangling pointer
case fifty percent of the objects we
free to ten malik's too soon which is
you know I mean freshman computer
science programmers don't do this dad
right maybe forty percent okay so if you
run it with G leaps G let's see crashes
every single time if you run it with die
hard this is for the espresso benchmark
by the way nine out of ten run correctly
with overflows you know unsurprisingly
if you overflow every object if you
under allocate every object things die
fast so we did it in a one percent
frequency and every object was under
allocated you know one percent of the
time by four bytes so G lipsy crashed
nine out of ten times and then there was
an infinite loop on the 10th execution
we're infinite means ran longer than
five minutes and diehard it ran 10 out
of 10 times correctly that is the output
was identical to the correct run so we
also measured it on real false so there
are two applications to relapse that we
used one is this web cache a popular web
cache called squid and it had an
overflow that crashed BTW and g live sea
ran at 10 times no apparent effect and
with mozilla there was a dangling
pointer error like I said before
dangling pointer protection is actually
really really high so it causes a denial
of service attack and julep see in
Windows you go to particular webpage the
browser freezes but if you run it with
diehard nothing happens yes one country
the process this is one copy some amount
of revision this is one copy to X ok
thank you for viewing better that's
right in principle so certainly you
could withstand more overflows the
dangling pointer protection is so good
replicas do add something but you're
already at you know 90 some percent the
intuition here is got a big heap I free
an object too soon now I need to
override it well random random random
random right when am I going to hit that
object right so the heap is large
relative to the number of objects or if
the heap is large and I'm allocating
randomly it's highly unlikely i'm going
to hit that object soon ok so conclusion
um here are those cores again so
randomization and replicas gives you
probabilistic memory safety in fact
replicas are not necessary you can use
you know you can just use this as a
plug-in replacement for your memory
allocator
clearly it provides more protection you
have today which is zero percent uh and
i think it's a useful point between
absolute soundness where the program
stops and unsoundness and you know the
take home here is look we have this
hardware let's use it and this is what
ECC does this is what raid does and you
trade hardware for liability and takes
advantage of these Hardware trends
certainly multi-core CPUs and memories
are getting larger if you have a small
to medium sized footprint application
then replication is fine for very large
footprint application just pushing the
limits you don't want to use diner okay
that's the end you can go to my web page
of course has these links as well but
you can download die hard there's a
linux and solaris version that
standalone and replicated the windows
version is standalone only well somebody
can explain to me how to how to do fork
in windows and MN flux if you go to flux
CS at umass it's actually a web server
written in flux and you can do the
bittorrent and it's the flux BitTorrent
so that's kind of cute and that's it
thanks for attention